[Musique]
c'est la course contre la montre avant
l'arrivée de randonneurs en vacances
nous sommes en juin les violentes
intempéries de mai ont déraciné des
milliers d'arbres dans lanaudière et les
laurentides
[Musique]
objectif couper les arbres morts qui
pourrait s'abattre sur dix randonneurs
et dégager le sentir les armes tomberont
portes
après le passage nous sommes sur le
territoire de la sépaq près de l'entrée
de la réserve faunique mastigouche au
nord de mandeville le sentier que réal
martel et ses bénévoles sécurisé même au
sentier national du québec
we can ou non à pied à l'accueil de la
sépaq on explique notamment aux
randonneurs comment s'y rendre c'est peu
entretenues par la sepaq c'est vraiment
des bénévoles du chantier national qui
viennent entretenir les sentiers sont
importants ce ménage oui c'est important
c'est ce sont des rats donna les
apprécie beaucoup
le sentier national a d'ailleurs été
fondée par un bénévole nul autre que
réal martel
une bonne foi les au québec pourquoi
qu'on a loupé notre propre ressenti
alors 1,89 j'ai sorti mes mais mes
cartes et puis j'ai dessiné un sentier
qui traverserait la province ce parcours
2006 150 km s'échelonne désormais de
l'outaouais jusqu'en gaspésie
du renfort pour réal martel ce groupe
arrive de saint-alexis-des-monts leur
chef d'equipe est responsable d'un autre
enfant la plupart des gestionnaires non
ici avec les arbitres
la sépaq gère 1450 km sur dix sept mille
kilomètres de sentiers québécois les
municipalités et les mrc font un bout de
chemin
mais chez rando québec on est
catégorique c'est le milieu
communautaire qui fait presque tout la
majorité des réseaux de sentiers ses
administrés par des organismes sans but
lucratif et par des bénévoles dont
qu'ils amènent tout leur matériel ils
achètent des outils
à la suite des violentes tempêtes
rendent au québec a demandé une aide
financière exceptionnelle d'urgence de
150 mille dollars pour aider les
bénévoles la demande d'aidé financière
de rands au québec à tourner en rond de
ministère en ministère de fonctionnaires
en fonctionnaires l'organisme a
finalement essuyé un refus à la mi juin
sous prétexte qu aucun programme
n'existe pour financer l'entretien des
sentiers et donc qu'il n'y aura pas de
financement de sous quand la chercher
des papiers sont le symbole est du
financement qui aurait notamment permis
d'acheter de nouvelles cimes et yannick
real devra réparer la sienne deux fois
durant notre tournage
le fondateur du sentier national dit ne
pas comprendre le gouvernement c'est
qu'il n'y a pas compris que c'est c'est
pour la santé des jeunes aussi
confessant les touristes des touristes
puis la santé sont grogne
le gouvernement le goût a appelé à
plusieurs reprises les québécois à
profiter de la nature durant la pandémie
quand vous êtes seul vous allez prendre
une belle marche dans la forêt ça vous
vous calmez de les prendre de l'air y
fait beau les gens ont tendance à penser
qu'un sentier de randonnée ça se fait
tout seul c'est pas le cas c'est
énormément de travail sur sa baraka qui
donne pas de l'argent aux autres
fédérations sportives le ministère des
transports a injecté 15 millions de
dollars dans des programmes voués
spécifiquement à l'entretien et la
sécurité des sentiers de motoneige de
véhicules tout terrain et de motos hors
route en 2022 radio-canada a interpellé
plusieurs ministères aucun programme
similaire dédiée au financement des
sentiers pédestres n'existe et le
gouvernement le goût confirme ne pas
avoir l'intention d'en créer un c'est
toujours les mêmes bénévoles qui sont là
mais aujourd'hui son vieillissant ces
gens là
facteur à la retraite réal martel père
de quatre enfants et grand père de six
petits enfants n'est pas un homme de
mots mais d'actions
le site est sécurisé et maintenant
il ne le dira jamais dans ces mots là
mais le sentier national et le projet
d'une vie pour lui il espère qu'il vivra
aussi après lui ici julie marceau
radio-canada dans la réserve faunique
mastigouche